this weather is perfect for nascar too
so nascar weekend and it makes it even
more special this weekend because the
fans will be back in the stands
jc is live at las vegas motor speedway
with more hey jc
hey lindsay and rocky i tell you what
you can feel the energy here at the
speedway and the races haven't even
started this is jeff motley
with the speedway jeff what can fans
expect when they come out here this
weekend
well we're going to see three great days
of racing we're going to start off
tonight with our truck race the bucked
up 200.
i'll just go 300 tomorrow for the
xfinity series and then on sunday
the big race depends on 400 for the
nascar cup series now normally out here
with what 80 000 screaming fans how many
fans are coming out this weekend we'll
have about 10 000 in our grandstands and
about another 2500 in our suites all
three days
uh we're sold out for all three days i
mean that's exciting but we'd like to
have a lot more people here we're used
to having
75 and 80 000 people packed in here now
with the race coming up this weekend are
there any story lines we should be
following i know your buddy you're close
friends with kurt busch
he won back here in september are there
any story lines we should be following
this week
a lot of local story lines you know kyle
busch is going to run tonight in the
truck race he's probably the favorite
a couple of local kids riley herbs noah
gregson going to be running in the race
on saturday
and of course kurt trying to go for two
in a row on sunday with his brother kyle
a lot of local story lines going on
there now the the grand marshal a very
special grand marshal on sunday who's
doing the call derek carr quarterback of
the raiders we're looking forward to
having derek out um i think he's gonna
bring bring a couple of
family members out with him too and uh
yeah it's pretty exciting you know we're
really trying to be
a great community partner here and the
sports in this community
has really worked together we work great
with the golden knights the aviators the
raiders
and it's a great great camaraderie we've
gotten to be able to get derek carr to
come out
and do the grand marshal i think that's
gonna be really cool it's gonna be great
i gotta rap here in a second but what
are we looking at these these haulers
are these the nas cars themselves or the
trucks
this is the nascar camping world truck
series haulers and you'll see some of
the trucks are already parked on pit
road ready for tonight there's no
practice there's no qualifying they
unload them from the trucks
put them on pit road the driver is going
to climb in fire the engines let's go
and here we go nascar is back in las
vegas this is so exciting it's going to
be an
awesome weekend we'll have more coming
up in the four o'clock hour
in fact let's get a check of the
weekend's weather and shut it over to
sherry right now